even stand up like I was doing barking I
was handing out flyers and stuff and and
then they were like you can help choose
who we bring down and I was like you
should bring Bill Burr down and they
were like really and I was like yeah
bill I sent them the link of you you got
me a gig yeah I got you a gig and uh and
you were really cool to me and and uh it
was right after that Yankees reliever
flew into the uh into Midtown in that
building because I remember you said uh
I still remember this conversation
because you said
um so funny it's like it's like because
like I relate now so much to you because
I'm like oh someone would be like I open
for you I'm like I do a lot of gigs but
like at that moment for me it was like
such a big moment right you know and uh
I remember we were talking about it and
you were like do you see this [__] and I
was like yep you're a Red Sox fan you're
like I'm not that big a [__] Red Sox
fan I was like oh [__] but you were
really cool and you were really
encouraging you were like just keep at
it you know and uh
yeah it was I was I mean and then I
think it was like 10 years later we were
on Conan together and you were like I
know you're from somewhere I'm like you
don't it's just I have a face